faut une véritable équipe nouvelle qui
n'a pas franc jeu dynamique audacieuse
pour pouvoir proposer un projet à
vocation je considère que mes
concurrents sont soit aux affaires ou
l'ont été à un moment donné où se sont
déjà présentés à plusieurs reprises sont
des caciques de la politique qu'on
revoie élection après élection
je crois que la population a besoin pour
pouvoir projeter c'est joseph dans ses
15 20 prochaines années avant
véritablement une équipe qui est de
cette génération là et qui comprend les
choses comme elles sont on aurait pu
faire effectivement c'est un
rapprochement les choses de pour le
moment ils ne sont pas figées en fin de
mon côté je suis pas fermé à ça mais je
crois que l'expression démocratique nous
donne une dizaine de candidats on va
fermer